la a 5 ans elle est venue avec Oscar
qu'est-ce qu'on lui a fait Oscar don des
médic l'
opér on lu bandage à la tte pour mal à
la
tête prière étape la consultation par le
médecin
un bandage autour de la tête du nounours
direction la radiographie pour voir ce
qu'il y a dans le ventre d'Oscar bon
alors moi ce que je propose c'est qu'on
fasse une photo du ventre de
Oscar pour regarder si on voit les
bonbons qu'il a trop mangé d'accord ve
bien qu'one ça
oscar a mangé une sucette et le bâton
avec il faut donc
l'opérer direction le bloc blous
charlotte sur la tête sur le visage léa
est prête voilà maintenant que tu es
prête à aller au bloc il y a plus qu'à
prendre
Oscar sa radiographie et son carnet de
santé et tu Mones tout ça au chirurgien
d'accord allez c'est juste
là anesthésie pince coton perfusion tout
est réaliste un hôpital des nounours
pour les enfants de 5 à 7 ans proposé
par poem une association qui regroupe
des étudiants de la Faculté de médecine
de 50 ans en Yveline l'objectif
dédramatiser le passage par l'hôpital et
l'effet blouse blanche sur des enfants
dont c'est souvent un univers inconnu il
y en a qui sont très à l'aise qui qui
sont peut-être plus adaptés au milieu
médical alors que il y en a qui sont
vraiment effrayés enfin quand on voit un
enfant qui pleure bon bah c'est vrai
qu'on a vraiment envie de le rassurer et
il faut vraiment tout leur expliquer et
leur expliquer que ils auront pas mal ou
alors qu'ils vont
sentir un petit pic ou quelque chose
mais expliquer ce qu'ils vont ressentir
pour pas que ce so soit l'inconnu en
fait je pense qu'ils ont plus peur de
l'inconnu que que que les soins qu'on
leur fait cette initiative est née il y
a maintenant 10 ans d'abord développé en
Allemagne une pratique qui rassure aussi
les parents je pense que ça dédramatisé
un petit peu le côté hospitalier ça leur
apprend aussi comment ça marche une
radio comment ça marche quand on arrive
à l'hôpital c'est c'est très très bien
et la mal à la suie et aussi la
varicelle et ben on va soigner la fille
on lui a mis du produit qui qui enlève
les bouton l'an passé 35 facultés de
médecine à travers la France ont
participé à cette initiative 3000
étudiants volontaires qui ont reçu
quelques 10000
enfants